Wow so he so girl looks like he's having
a pretty good time at the moment wonder
what he's doing oh oh I mean look I
guess that's one way to smash that
subscribe button so uh enjoy I guess
hello and welcome to the new old review
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are yeah kind of
stretching that definition a bit I guess
because here's the thing
I am a 30 year old Straley man and being
of the ancient existence I am I don't
often use things like say you've read it
however it does happen on the odd
occasion and this time in particular I
found myself going down a bit to the
deep spiral of hunt hunter and really I
just found so much cool stuff that I did
one share it with all of you there
really is no greater purpose to this
video than that but I mean most of my
viewers on this channel seem to harbor
an unhealthy level of love for hunt
hunter just as I do so I think you are
very much going to enjoy this and if you
are interested in what you see then
there will be links to the various
reddit threads in either the description
or a print comment I haven't quite
decided at the time of this recording
because I'm aloof like that but it will
be one of them let's dive down this
rabbit hole and begin with the thing
that really sparked my whole endeavor
which was seeing this glorious custom
kill a Nintendo switch and I just don't
even all of a sudden my switch seems
absurdly boring and it just so happens
to use one of my all-time favorite shots
of kilowatt which goes during the hunter
exam after here brutally dismissed
Botero from life there's just something
so schmick about it with the blood
dripping down from his eye and it works
super well in this context
plus a little chibi killer with the
electricity is adorable
I want it brilliant work speaking of
brilliant here is nothing less than a
brilliant idea
a classic Ilima themed pin cushion and
the detail on the face here is pretty
phenomenal but I do see one problem with
this though which is that I would never
actually want to remove one of the pins
because it would begin to break the
aesthetic it's pretty damn creepy
actually I mean imagine inviting someone
over who had never seen or read Han
dontoh and introducing them to this that
would be an awful lot of questions to
answer so let me know down in the
comments is this a stroke of genius or
is it a cursed construct designed to
generate nothing but nightmare fuel well
both there's no reason why we can't have
both at least that's what the taco had
told me okay confession time I may or
may not have thought that this was
biscuit first while scrolling through
the subreddit but jumping onboard with
the Sailor Moon trend
here we have the silver zoldak
incarnation and doesn't he look simply
thrilled to be fighting evil by
moonlight and winning love by daylight
boss I'm certain that silver would never
run from a real fight so it's pretty
perfect yeah next up is something that
obviously catches my eye in particular
which is a great crossover series of fan
art by tindy flow and it's a series of
drawings that appears to depict
one-piece characters interacting with
Hunter hunter characters and in this
specific one we see Luffy going up
against Corolla which I have to say is
it's an interesting idea if you're
familiar with one piece in any way shape
or form it would probably be really
tempting to call Luffy the victim
because of raw physicality but at the
same time he is also the height of
mental ineptitude and maybe crawlers
sheer intellect could actually overcome
him I honestly don't know actually I
guess it also depends on the abilities
he currently has access to it's go
hunter by the way it looks really really
good
I like the line art a lot and I
specially enjoy crawlers face because he
just looks so supremely bored by the
situation whereas in contrast if you
look so endlessly excited there's such a
mismatch of personality and yeah once
again there are a whole series of these
one piece and hunt under crossovers but
I won't show them all here because I
have an entire separate challenge focus
on one piece thank you for making not
you hunter hunter the best anime and I
mean is there really anything to argue
with you where would hunter hunter even
be without supreme characters like tompa
the rookie crusher or the undisputed
best antagonist ever written again
through and I feel dirty even trying to
make a jerk about that last one well
look as much as this is just a shot of
me me goodness does kind of highlight
how Takashi tends to create these really
odd characters just exist and disappear
like wings specifically I guess and it's
kind of funny because my wife is just
now finishing Kevin's arena and she
still expects him to make a return at
some point because yeah he seems like a
character who's being set up to be a
more perpetual presence and yeah she
still has yet to learn what hunter
hunter truly is I kind of like it though
gives Ceres more realistic feel the fact
that you can encounter one character one
time and then just never see them again
because that's life
substitute teacher walks in class clowns
this is actually kind of perfect
especially that grin on he soaked his
face now I'm certainly not a teacher and
the world is probably quite grateful for
that but in high school I do recall that
overwhelming feeling of I guess let's
call it potential when a sub
- teacher walked in and it was like
everyone's eyes immediately shifted to
the biggest delinquent in the class
because we knew what they were capable
of meanwhile that substitute had no idea
what they were getting themselves into
it's kind of like gone and Kilwa
arriving on to the two hundred four of
heavens arena with no knowledge of Nan
whatsoever except for the poor
substitute there was no wing-like figure
to stop them getting initiated in the
classroom so this is actually a reach
roaring of quite possibly one of my
favorite panels to ever come out of the
hunt onto manga which happens during the
Dark Continent expedition arc knees I
stomp approaches crop occur and piques
his interest shall we say regarding the
topic of the Scarlet eyes and kropog er
goes full murder monster and says from
this point on choose your words wisely
so I love it it is a genuinely
terrifying kropog a moment and this
redrawing of it is pretty damn cool it
doesn't quite convey the [ __ ] terror of
the original but I do enjoy how sleek it
is and even the fact that it's covered
in a violent glow of aura which I don't
think was in the original panel but the
shading is also really cool the
proportions are great and just yeah
really enjoying the style oh dear
something has gone very very very wrong
here let's just move on all right now
this on the other hand is a thing of
pure beauty Hunter hunter picks a lot
everything about these are phenomenal
and I don't know if they're inspired by
sprites of an actual game or not but if
they are original and even more props to
the artists here who I believe is Kyrie
Menominee and what is there even to
fault about what's going on here all of
the poses are great i specially enjoyed
gaunt and even stuff like the oreo
suitcase looks so fantastic and here is
one of my many problems with me going on
reddit because once I scrolled down I
realized that this poster actually sells
these pixel figures and look I may or
may not have immediately ordered the
entire set of four from their Etsy store
which is pixi pixels design and you'll
find a link in the thread if you're keen
but yeah I wasn't expecting to spend
money especially not that much money but
it's done now and I guess I don't regret
it
I don't even know where I'm going to put
them for that that's a problem for
future Liam totally was it cannot wait
to get them now look I'm not one to
define what art is in fact who is
anybody to tell someone that something
is art and something is not this is a
question that modern and postmodern
artistic movements have been grappling
throughout their and
tenure in this world however I think
that we can all easily come to it
bipartisan agreement in this particular
case because this ladies and gentlemen
is nothing short of high art don't even
try to argue against it I mean I can
picture myself walking right into the
art gallery of New South Wales which is
the the fanciest gallery near me and
seeing that's proudly displayed on their
primary feature wall as you walk in
which is unfortunate because you know
after seeing this magnum opus of the art
community there would actually be no
reason to look any further into the
gallery because quite simply nothing is
going to top this experience good stuff
all right so this image comes for the
title why are gone shorts so short and
it's a great question really especially
when examining this because actually
like let's start at the top gone and
kilowatt or more or less exactly the
same height but the further down you get
the crazier the proportions become
kilowatt would appear to have what I
call a normal human sized torso whilst
guns is almost non-existent us meaning
we reaches but much faster and combined
with his fashion choices of short shorts
it leads to let's say an excess of leg
it's kind of like gone doesn't really
have a stomach and furthermore kilwa
even realizes this because look at his
eyes look at where they're looking
kilowatt is staring straight at guns
chest and wondering where it actually is
strange indeed
so more krohler found out now and this
is out of perfection I've never seen
fish look more threatening than in this
image plus it features by far my
favorite crawler look this york new suit
and bandana combination is peak crow low
aesthetic in my opinion and honestly I'm
actually kind of disappointed to see his
regular design when it pops up because
to me this look just feels superior in
every way tell me I'm not the only one
who thinks that
or alternatively feel free to tell me
that I am a raving mad man I the one
works what we will all agree on though
is that this is beautiful especially the
texture on the suit because it just
makes the whole thing feel so nice and
tangible so this image is entitled the
entrance to my town is turning me on and
look I'm not a huge fan of Animal
Crossing but by far the best part about
this phenomena is seeing what kind of
amazingness fans come up with and this
is brilliant
I would certainly feel something upon
entering a town whereby your initial
greeting is this and they also really
like that the character down here is so
decked out in brogue are looking like an
so boss although he is standing
dangerously close to the tongue if he
Sokka there I'm not sure if I'd want to
be that close and you know this is
actually the kind of thing I wish we saw
more of in street art on pavements and
such just Hisoka Hisoka everywhere I'm
sure it could only make the world a
better place and next up we have
something the very much made me do a
literal allall by turning the cast of
hunt hunter into the Powerpuff Girls
complete with a professor lay Oreo and
everything and isn't it just uncanny how
well gone and Kilwa in particular seem
to fit into this art style it is kind of
trippy though because you do need to ask
who's who I mean gone seems like
Buttercup because of the green color
scheme but with the long hair and being
the ringleader and all he could also be
blossom and killer would appear to be
bubbles because of the blue but at the
same time the blonde hair of karapa is
also a very bubbles like trait to have
whilst Karaka is also at the Hadas which
is a very Buttercup thing to do so
interesting mixture here mmm anyway
brilliant work and here we have more
stunning artwork that further reinforces
that every creative thing I've ever
tried to do and will ever try to do in
my lifespan will consistently forever be
overshadowed by random reddit users
seriously though this thing is pretty
Wow especially the masterful shading
going on and just like with the karapa
courage I love that there is an aura
around marijuana
he looks pretty damn amazing like you
could have ripped him straight out of
the manga except this probably looks
even better and you know what it
definitely looks better because the
Chimera ant arc really does constitute a
darker stage of took ah she's art and
now is it just me well is this image not
as cursed as one may initially think to
me it really just does seem like Lee ro
has gained a massive confidence boost
all of a sudden and is about to destroy
some fools with some kind of strange
Bungie knife I really want to see the
reverse face swap though one with he
soaked his body in the air his face just
to see what a potentially pitiful
existence he so could become if his dark
persona just so happened to be misplaced
in the body of an aspiring doctor and
lastly for this video we have an acrylic
painting which man I'm glad that you
don't have an Etsy store that I know of
anyway because I may very well have
bought something like this as well
there's a really great dynamic happening
here in terms of composition color
choice and even the texture of the white
and red Boz it's all just very very
appealing plus they've chosen some
really strong screenshots of the 2011
anime as inspiration for the characters
a spare
Ashley with gone and crop akka and look
I need to stop talking about this now
because I'm quite literally mentally
calculating exactly where on my walls
this would go so well done it's
fantastic and once again look I have no
real idea why I did this it was a bit of
a whim related video but I did really
enjoy exploring what the greater hunter
hunter fan base has to offer and if you
won't see more stuff like this then
please please please do let me know in
the comments all by adding a like to the
video because those are really the only
solid metrics I have to go by and if
there is anything hunt a hunter related
on reddit that you want to draw my
attention to then please do go ahead and
do that as well but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my disco
server and if you keen for some more
hunt onto content then please do go and
check out my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
Hunter hunter glory delivered straight
until YouTube feed but for now this has
been the new alt review and I'll see you
next time